thanks Sarah right so i will give the
third walk of the series the first two
are given by g and then in this talk i
will talk about these are planar just a
call me seven for planar instances the
rough outline of what i'm going to talk
about so I first lady review some of the
notions annotations that has already
been covered by GE and that will move on
to some tractable cases this is also
mostly covered by Cheney already and
then in the end we will discuss some
hardees proofs and implicates particular
lima that is I've useful in our the
columns theorem and it's kind of
necessary show some techniques that we
use very often ok let's start so first
of all we have our favorite problem the
counting while the CSP constraint
satisfaction problems and we are
interested in the conversion so again we
have a set of variables and we have a
set of constraint and we connect them if
a variable is in a constraint and
equivalently we can view this as a
hypergraph or equivalent like a
Parrothead graph so formula we have this
definition and we have a private a graph
and we sort of label the constraint set
by a function from certain function set
f and we want to compute this particular
function which is sum of product quality
and it is sum over all possible
assignments of the variables and the
weight of each particular configuration
is just a product over all functions ok
and here we are mostly interested in the
complexity in terms of these functions F
F so we know like a set is hard we know
um not very easy in planar graph is easy
on so our question is like when is it
hot
when it is easy because that's the
classification program and one of the
central problem in counting contacts
today is to count the number of perfect
matchings in a graph this is one of the
first number PR problem introduced by
valid okay it's just a brief reminder of
what a perfect matching is and our goal
is to count the number of such
structures such perfect matchings in a
graph and somehow for counting probably
matching is not really a CSP because for
example we have this paper by Friedman
of our spanish river income the approval
but is shown that the counting problem
matching is not expressible in some
so-called vertex assignment models which
is very similar to graph form of them
and spin systems so it's somewhat
difficult to express exactly in CSP but
we do have actually a acsp that is
equivalent in the approximation sense to
confirm imagine which is easing model
with some negative weights but here we
are may considering the exact
computation okay so that urges us to
consider this a little edge coloring
model and so we want to add to be
variables because we want pika
problematic we won't pick a subset of
edges and the verses are functions so
this gives our motivation of so-called
holding problems this is because this
some this won't be the first is denoted
by a balanced he call this Holland so
the instance is given a graph and we
have these edges at variables and we
label each vertex by us or the function
from again from set of functions and
we'll compute this some more product
quantity you may already notice this is
sort of a special CSV problem we are
every variable up here it's exactly
twice so sometimes it's the call so
called I green twice ESP
but that's like a restriction on the
instant instance side but we are
interested in sort of the complexity
with respect to the function set so in
that point of view this is actually much
other than context ESP because we can
simulate the common CSP by easily
through in all the Equality functions
since if we have a variable that appears
80 times then we can just replace it by
a equality function of heredity this
actually goes both ways so if we have a
peck on the theorem for all function set
for Holland then as a consequence we
have it economy for chronic CSP so in
distance is slightly more general and
they are this is actually has been
studied before there are some equivalent
formulation such as like a minute while
CSP I'm a graphical CSP and also this is
equivalent to test a network contraction
this is how these things sort of
connected to quantum computation because
quantum circuit can be viewed as tensor
netbook and and here is the notation PL
volunteers just means how every input
graph is planar and so let's see a brief
example we'll hope we can express
counting profit matching as a whole so
what we do is just we put to this exact
one function on every vertex and not as
a way to actually different functions
when their degree is different neck
exactly one of the theory goes well act
for when the degrees s.coups three or
four and then the counting how perfect
matching is is just this Z as the
partition function okay and as i said
earlier calling profile matching is one
of the first number V ha the problem
given by valid okay define this cause
but like a roughly attack the earlier is
already know there's a polynomial time
algorithm for to count profile matchings
in planar graphs and this is the
so-called f katie hours and all
custodians autism is via [ __ ]
orientations of cleaner
this is what they talk about in the
first talk and also valid have this
wonderful idea of holographic algorithms
the kind of extend the reach of the fkd
algorithms so as we understand now like
this roughly have the two ingredients
first we have these match gates so
roughly speaking these are the functions
that can be expressed by perfect
matchings also be a planar carriage as
in the androids talk about callousness
we restrict to planar because we want to
solve the problem in the end by these
fkd algorithm which only works for
planar and the second ingredient is that
these whole graphical transformations
which is roughly a change of basis let's
briefly review what a holographic
transformation is so we use this
notation Holland f G to denote the case
where the input is actually a by
paragraph and on the one side is f and
on the other side we get G we need to
consider paragraphs because we want to
apply transformation will apply T on one
side and TV versus on the other side and
this is actually quite useful because we
can always write a whole as a equality
to on the edge side by considering some
of the the edge vertex incidence graph
the transformation and here let's see a
another example of what holographic
transfer whole graphic hours and can do
I will talk about the easy model last
time je talk about something cause a
planar through regular not all equal ice
model this is sort of a something new
that wouldn't matter to introduce it
would it would matter to introduce
holographic algorithms this is a new
problem that can be solved but there is
the exists is this is easing what are
sort of more classical and already known
to be solvable we can do it in terms of
this whole graph
our sins so these in model just give
some ad interaction beta 1 beta and we
sort of give assignment to every vertex
like 01 or blue or red or like plus
minus spins or States or whatever we
have these interactions if they are
equal k beta if is DC code give one and
each configuration have this weight
which is multiply all eddies and the
probability of a particular sigma is
actually proportional to the weight and
we are interesting calculating this
position function which is sum over all
possible such configurations okay and
rather easy without field is a tractable
problem and to show that way first we
recall some notation this bracket
notation for symmetric function we just
at least its entries due by hiding wait
so I've eyes like the entry is a
function value when the input has hang
with I and using this notation we will
write our equality is like 100 1 it is
one on if and only for all and all
inputs are 0 or inputs are 1 and like
the perfect matching function exact one
function is 0 1 0 0 that is it is one
exactly when one of the input is 1 and
the easing function is like beta 1 beta
it's a binary function because it's put
on edge and again as I explained earlier
this the easing is like sort of a CSP
and we can be very vertex as equality
function and if you know that if there's
a external field that we will have a
channel as you call people here would
cost an awful case so we have a weighted
equality and then we can write easing me
in this way so we have a sort of
equality is on one side and have this
beta 1 beta on the other side is that we
will do this transformation H which is
the automatic matrix and
and the this H is is self the universe
so when we do a transformation go to a
channel both side and on the right-hand
side we rewrite this equality in sort of
a tensor form which is 10 to 1030 or + 0
1 to infinity so again the same vector
is sent to the deal inspector which is
one if it's all 0 or 1 and we can
distribute each other computers and here
I ignored some constant factor because
it doesn't affect the complexity so we
get this expression which is basically a
parody function it is one if I know if
are the way it's even gets me and on the
other side on the left side we do the
same sort of thing but notice that here
we view the vectors as as low vectors
here we on the other side of ability as
a column vector because it's sort of a
huge dot product and with the
transmission we get something like Peter
plus 1 comma 0 come with a medicine and
Jeanne last time give a explicit table
of what with a symmetric basket and both
of them are match case so we can express
these as perfect matchings and then
solve it use I've KPRC so this this self
of transformation is out also these
so-called Heidi high temperature
expansion or something called the sub
graph was because edge functions are
transformed into a sort of a weighted
equality so Peter so you look at this
video peter plasma over him as well as a
white then it's serrated equality so
it's like picking a subset of edges and
essentially the the German Sinclair of
Peters for ferromagnetic be easing is
under this view as well and we haven't
even generalizes he also the dominance
SQ by replacing the transformation by
our discrete Fourier transformation
we will get some more cute gate here and
some kind of ecology here but that
doesn't seem to give us any use for
example but in the bullying case is
quite a hundy it gives us the planar
track 12 hours Amanda gave us the FPS
all right so we have these holographic
algorithms and we're going to introduce
them he called it somewhat accidental
organisms so we won't understand the
water they're real power I will carry
complete with Alan architect and the
genie and his collaborators has doesn't
make extensive work to understand the
power of with holographic algorithm can
solve but the question still is not that
self I because we're still under like
what about those that can't solve and
that's motivates our classification
program so and we noticed in some of
previous works on these counting
problems that they are defined by local
constraint and the Uralic can be
classified into three classes so the
first days those that are tractable
these are polynomial time even general
rafts second count is like the heart in
general grass water soluble in planar
graphs exactly likely coming from match
exactly match gates and so how some kind
exactly is very very hot it's even
harder in printed maps and as well the
the second category is sometimes you
really like always captured by or
graphic origin with the match gates here
are some examples such as top 10 meters
and to spin systems and pulling counting
CSP of design in existence again however
last year we discover that for playing
the holiday it's not quite the same it's
somewhat ironical because Holland is the
framework where we should consider
perfect matching but for those that this
is not the case we have one extra
let a planar solved by the hardy gel so
again we have lists economy we will we
have a set of functions which is
symmetric and the compacts waited and
pooling and i will show that this
problem is number three hard unless one
of the case will happen so first case is
that it's trackable even in general
rafts without a planar restriction the
second kind is this transformation such
that it became a imagicate so that means
it's solo by holographic awesomes and
the third can't is some somewhat special
kind of counting orientation problems as
change said last time twenty
orientations is just to put a DC quality
function on the edge side which is
equivalent to a normal home setting by
the 11 msi transformation we are
considering in complex ways so that that
is also in our free book and the first
class is characterized by all previous
work correct three years ago and the
third one is the orientation problems
somehow not captured by a walk awesome
and it will discuss the party to a
little bit later now let's move on to
the practical cases I will go through
these travel cases but G has already
explained some of them so i will not
give much detail the first class is so
called affine functions so basically you
have a a alpha support indicated by this
character function i have i to some
karate form here will require be to be
symmetric therefore the cross terms will
always have even coefficient and this is
called a fan because your generalization
of like a fan linear systems we can call
the solution to a linear systems right
and this is a generalization to that and
the interesting this also corresponds to
something called a cleaver case
in quantum computation which is
classical which can be simulated
classically efficiently well the reason
is tractable so the world is do or some
consistent okay and the second type is
this product would happen if it's great
products of equality and DC quality this
is a very easy to solve because we can
just propagate and the subclass is match
case these are only tractable on planar
graphs which gene has covered in his
previous two talks and the last days is
that is vanishing cases which will solve
always written 0 I think changing it
didn't have the time to talk about this
so i will talk more about this few
slides okay robot vanishing know there's
a proof a picture they vanished okay on
most servers so first observation is
like one eye is vanishing this is very
simple you two dot product of two Isaac
always got zero and we can do something
more complicated we can support we have
degenerates signature degenerative
function which means it can be
decomposed into a bunch of unit ones and
suppose we have more than half of these
unit was a la that this must be
vanishing because whenever you have this
function only this function in using the
instance in this office as a netbook you
can always decompose it and there will
be more than half wide in the network
then 22 of them will definitely match
whatever you align them then whenever
these matches gives you a factor of 0
keeps the whole making the whole sum 0
but the small party because this is not
symmetric function so we need some more
semi transit here's the definition of
some symmetrization operation which is
just some of sum sum over all possible
permutations of these unit ones it's
very easy to understand once you read
our example
so here we see me try this y0 one thing
and we thought these three songs are
these three terms and we have this
factor of two because when we swap while
eyes it's the same thing and we'll get
this expression so after we seem tries
it we can view it as a superposition of
likes of three functions
rate-determining functions we either go
to this one or call this one or got that
10 when we have an instance of these
functions on we will do everything
perhaps has in one of the three states
it gives one of the three functions and
then we can write the whole and some in
3 to the N many terms this this is yuri
not very useful because it's a stoic
special song and it doesn't really give
us any efficient algorithm but it does
because whenever we're at it this way we
will have more than half my eyes and in
the hole in the whole graph no matter
how we put these things there will
always be mono hop on I and 12 them will
match whenever it matches you gives us 0
also it's exponentially large sum every
term is 0 therefore the whole sum is
still there so that's basically the idea
of this vanishing stuff and as gene said
we can throw in something wrong so that
is the whole summer in the end is not
necessarily 0 it's actually a little
more than this but this is rough idea
and so a few comments on these check
more cases the first is that this is a
cabbage and here is the so the
expression of these sketches this andrea
has discussed of all Gary's
constructions in detail and here I won't
point out that like this is a Mac if a
tractable class is maximal then it has
to be closed under constructions and in
fact all of these four classes the self
is and more importantly the kind of
satisfy efficient guided the
construction
what do I mean by that so we actually
have a universal approach to all of
these four track of all cases so it has
several tube two ingredients again first
of all we have a succinctly
representation our spy succinctly main
polynomial size in terms of this
Saturday and this seems to be trivial
for symmetric function because we can
just list the sort of the team at T plus
1 many entries is definitely a
polynomial but in fact that all these
four cases so we can define them for
asymmetric ones and wednesdays matrix
has potentially to to the mla these two
today many information but it always
exists a singlet representation for any
update cost like a four-hour fine we
really only need to store the
information for the matrix a and b are
each one which is like n by n so it
second Squire Mary piece our tab is easy
to do is likely near them anyway many
bits and the match case this is due to
Medicaid identities we actually only
need n square many peas or Big O of n
square many bits to memorize who saw a
magic eight and vanishings as well as
academia okay but that's not enough many
function has this succinct
representation but this succinctly
representation can be updated
efficiently whenever we do the following
two basic operations so we have this
operation which is sort of this is all
also showed by jadyn last talk for the
Fibonacci gates so basically we have two
two functions we just connect one edge
among them and it will view it as a new
function and the second move is that I
would have a function and the way just
do a self loop and they will view it as
a new function so notice that given any
graph we can repeatedly do these two
moves to construct a graph so given
instance we first cut
Eddie's that would connect them and when
they are in the same component to
collect them again is likely to do a
self loop and they will do this until we
have only saw one vertex left while
maintaining this 1630 presentation and
is the end we will get a new Larry
function unoriginal means there's no
input knowing evening's this on one
value which is exactly the whole result
okay in fact the algorithm for trainer
Ohio domain CSP described by decision is
somehow also fits in this paradigm it
seems to be a general theme of how these
things are tractable however this is
somewhat arbitrary like their menacing
has singled reputation and you may
imagine that many of them can be updated
efficiently but I our economy theorem
these are the only things like there
actually are not many more well there
are other cases that I will come I will
discuss later but their methods housing
Eddie this is actually not halt match
getting is solved you would imagine
because either way point out earlier
match case can be reduced to counting
perfect matchings and calling for
matching Z's like it will [ __ ]
orientation of the graph which is a
global thing rather than these local
moves but a due to magic is third due to
the magic eight identities we can verify
that this move will maintain the magic
and identity therefore it can be
understand it is what it is software
alternative proof for the gasoline
algorithm this is accurate into a new
compiling tisha
so if if we are considering CSP this we
should stop here like the CSV this is
this is it but i'm working in holland
and for all there's one more thing to
consider which is this whole debacle
transformations so here is the
definition of so-called f transformable
basically we write the whole inter in
this paper cut away and the way to a
transformation T and we'll put these two
functions together there's a compact
silica only increase and so we call this
f transvaal if we're both of these two
functions belong to the same set
function set f therefore we can reduce
this small F to script f the point is if
script F is tractable than any f
transformable functions is trackable
because it can be reduced to have by
these transformations is that
interestingly this managing set is
closed under these transformations I was
sort of intuitive because it always
gives zero like whatever transform is
all the kids here but the other three
are not so this is where things differ
from CSPI think in CSP only consider
these three cases and we don't need to
consider these confirmations and the
mall over like educated construction is
software community with transformation
so therefore we only need to consider a
gadget closer than considered
transformation closer and we don't need
to repeat this process to get solve a
maximal track focus and this through
these four cases actually the men travel
cases for plain Holland as a PM
transformable and the vanishing case
another view to transfer these clothes
on transformation is that sort of i 1
minus i business they are always the
eigenvectors of two by two or so images
Los Alamos risks will our preserve
equality ok
but notice that I said the results of
the men check more cases there's one
more case where we discovered which is
not really we started really fitting the
picture which I described earlier these
are some problems about counting
orientations remember that this is
equivalent to normal hold via this one 1
I minus I and our transformation and in
this orientation problems we consider
two kinds of notes the first kind is
like is exact one function it's like we
allow exactly one edge to come in and
the second kind is like equality
functions we allow our edges coming or
edges going out so these are either a
sink or source and we have further
requirement that's the GCD of all these
verses in the type 2 is at least fun
notice that we require requirement is
like GCD so you have a t25 and degrade
60 g series 1 and the problem is hot but
if you have like 5 10 15 which is 325
and the problem is easy somehow the
algorithm is kind of a cascading
phenomena because the instance has to be
planar and because this sort of degree
agility there will use this some
structure such that some of the eddies
has to be painted to 0 or 1 or there's
no cell phone your servant so we will
argue that the either such thing exists
all the instance can be solved by one of
the known cases IPO am so we'll repeat
this process we find the structure with
pinger edge and we found another
structure and simplified instance
furthermore in the end it will be a
solvable instance by known algorithms so
this is somewhat exotic and kind of
artificial problem but due to evolve
dichotomy theorem this is the last
missing piece like once we understand
this
everything else is so hard like never be
hot so there's no other way of cases
it's actually we stuck at this for quite
a while at first we saw this it has to
be hard because it's so weird somehow in
and it turns off easy that's a Maltese
of all the easy stuff let's talk more
about the hard proof I mean Harley's
proof okay so the general strategy of
our economy serum is kind of approval
they call me for a single function first
in general we won't consider set of
functions but it's somewhat too
complicated and we'll do a single family
first and we do an induction on the area
of the function so induction has like
sort of two steps will consider base
case and we consider an error it a
reduction procedure you release this
reduction is like a easier to do i thik
by altitude so we have to basically
three and four and once we have a single
that calls me then we want to show that
a different track for cases cannot mix
together if we even make some become hot
however is it like this is like the high
level of line but what we really do is
more of in convoluted things i can we
prove some single thing that we prove
some mixing that we use mixing to prove
another single thing and so on and the
real proof is more complicated than that
but this is a high drive idea and in
particular in this talk i will show a
concrete at lima and in fact we will
show that most of the article functions
are never be half this is one of the
base case where we have basically every
three or four and this is quite useful
lima i will see later it's called
handling the proofs or using the many
places later
so suppose we have a heretic for
function so we consider symmetric
functions so it has solid five entries
in the bracket notation f0 f1 f2 f3 f4
and then we write it in these matrix
notation which is the way so the index
two inputs as so two variables as input
and the two variable that output 6 and 0
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 1 on to index 0 and
similarly for the column and then we're
at it this way and in general for a a
symmetric function we can write down
this matrix G of 0 0 0 0 0 1 0 and so on
notice that usually we label the
variables counterclockwise but in this
matrix notation Rosa index like Xbox
silly and the columns X 4 X 3 will
reverse we swap the order here on this
is a user turns down with a picture so
with these three variables like
counterclockwise and we label this way
so that we concatenate two such
functions the resulting function has a
matrix which is just the product of the
two matrices here we use the Diamonds to
denote the most significant beach and
his most significant bits so like X for
alliance with s1 that's why we see this
way and and view it as a new function we
put them in here to notice the most
significant bit so this is a signature
matrices notation and in particular were
interested in these so called the
redundant matrices are we're really
interested in our symmetric functions
right and somehow symmetric functions
are too restricted
in this view so we slightly relax it we
consider redundant matrices which means
the middle two rows are equivalent are
identical and the middle two columns
identical as well and nothing if it's
symmetric that I've 1 equals I have one
Prime and F 2 prime equals I have two
aliquots have 2 double Prime and so on
so symmetric ones are symmetric
functions definitely have a redundant
matrix but reverse is not necessarily
true and the since it is redundant we
want to compress it so we have this
compression operation which is just a
sort to delete one row one of the
redundant rose and it deleted what
redundant a column and we put a 2 in the
column we need to put this too because
we want to maintain this to be a
systemic group as Muslims we want to
preserve the multiplication so defense
in the face in this way so that if MH is
like a MF one time that I choose and the
compression also has this modification
ok so here's the line i would like to
show here so let F part4 function with
complex which and the suppose the matrix
notation is redundant and the compress
matrix is non-singular then this problem
is hot so that means like many of the
problems are hard because our only
constraint is determined this is not 0
when you compress it ok so this we have
like three steps first of all we won't
show sort of a planar counting planar
for regular oil area orientations never
be hard this is what we covered in his
last talk but I think he didn't have a
time to explain the motivation this is
the motivation this is the why we
consider this problem
we first show this in hull I will not
repeat this part in this talk then we
will reduce of the identity element in
this semi group in the redundant
matrices can always reduce from the
counting on our library orientations in
planar for regular graphs to this
problem and lastly we show that
everything else can be reduced from the
identity element so the first part is
covered by Jeanne and I will talk about
the second and the third part that will
be rest of my talk okay so what is that
in the element corresponds to the i3 in
the GL Serena's three by three matrix so
we do we solve uncompress it we get
these matrix I have one in the corners
and we have to arrive for our house in
the middle remember that when we do the
compression we put our two in the column
so we'll get this and this event is hard
because we can reduce it from the
calculor and orientations remember that
content online orientation can be
written as holland by from selected DC
quality on the edge side then we do
transformation we actually get a integer
value the problems 30 103 so our
reduction will be from this 301 there
are three to edit and this reduction is
actually a approximation reduction so
somehow when we use scad is for
approximately counting Zack to use the
exact computation you tax reduction for
approximation problem here with me
reverse here we do an approximation
reduction for exact content problems the
idea is actually very simple we can
approximate this of this function
exponential accurately because our
problems are integrated and well here we
are just normalize it so that
it's like a rational waited the true
value will be like a in some grand
narrative like straight to the end so
the Madison so if we can approximately
to accurately enough like in the
exponential sense so we can just recover
the true value so we can recover the
executive compensation here is a
recursive construction how to
approximate this so first we have one
note then we do a rotation we put the
most significant beat rotating like 90
degrees and we attach another one and
again we do the rotation and we attach
another one with the rotation or attach
another one so what this is doing is
kind of complicated but we will show
that to this operation gives a very good
gives us a very good approximation of
this to claim that the matrix of this
gadget is something like this where I
sub K is like a third minus some
expression small error and what we want
exactly a third for all these six
entries so this is a very good
approximation and what we really do when
we do the rotation the entries goes in
these cycles and this is just a
pictorial extrusion so in this
construction with do a rotation than
these entries go along along these
cycles and we attach a new one which is
this half half thing and effectively
this is just average averaging the
middle two columns and it's not how
verified as the average of this sealed
are more closer to assess a capacity so
we can realize this we're in case I
exponentially accurate and we want to
approximate this now we only need to
make sure the error is smaller than
three to the minus n so we can recover
the exact value and it's not hard to
verify that so this works out when you
pick
k 2 k to be four times e okay so this is
a very simple proof fracture and let's
back to the Lima so we have shown the
identical huh then what do we need to
show is to reduce everything else to it
and this proof will be more complicated
and we will do it by the integration
technique which is very common use
technically in counting capacity and is
actually very strong so basic idea is
that say we have sort of a matching
polynomial then we will so we want to
write the holiday some as in some kind
of polynomial such as like matching
polynomial and we want to solve the
coefficient of the polynomial like each
coefficient ck is like a number of
matchings with Sasuke but here is
slightly more complicated than the
single variable polynomial but still
going on to this intonation ok what we
do is a sequential construction remember
that we wrote this we choose our
notation in this way so that a mop and s
is like MF to death power and we do this
recursive contraction is just to
multiply this one at a time ok and to do
the integration suppose that to the
identity appeared on times in the
original instance called Omega Omega is
basically the crap Jeep plus the
labeling and want to replace this
identity by the carriage so by this
carries we often hear a but we have an
index s so when we repeat this
construction as time we'll get some
instance color say Omega s and the
matrix is just this to that power so
when we have this matrix power which is
to the Java normal form and this in
generally you will have something like
this we have with some egg values lambda
1 and 2 lambda 3 and possibly 10
one beaches yeah we will consider a case
where all three eigenvalues equal and
post b1 b2 are one the reason is we'll
see later on that when we do the
integration we get some linear system
that is there will be singular in this
case in other cases you usually get a
non-singular not singular doing a system
either non singular venous system always
fun and order which means you can
directly realize identity here is a
little more tricky we will get a
singular system but we're still kind of
solve it so here is a little trick to do
the interpolation we know we can write
this as is T lambda to the esta tu m'as
but the original one we can also write
it in this way because its identity in
substance this is kind of a discrete
holographically transformation if you
think about it so what we do is to
replace each occurrence of these by
three matrices three functions each of
which corresponds to the three matrix T
or ID out the universe and similarly
here on the so what we care is the
contribution from this lambda or and
this society ok so we do some
stratification on we will consider
assignments to this this this matrix to
the S power according to like 0 0 0 to 2
I times and like 11 J times and so on we
have like solo in this picture we have a
matrix we have five nonzero entries for
the way to take this power on the corner
will also be nonzero so we have six
cases for the whip and 0 0 0 and two to
kiss together and any other assignment
will give the zero and in the original
instance because we have identical we
have 11 here so we only care about 0 0 1
1
tues now we can rewrite the whole and
some in terms of these see IDK rms so
this is similar to like a sake hey
matching polynomial in matching
polynomial it is just the number of
matchings of size K but here is some
assignment some contribution when the
assignment said if I the parameters I JK
RM they started it's just a five five
parameters for the same spirit it's
slightly more complicated okay and we're
at these holding some in this way then
in the original one because we only care
about I and J so all others are 0 to get
yourself we have this factor of two
because when we uncompress it we get a
half in the middle and for Omega s we
get this expression is not very hard
work out and so we have you see as you
care a mess and i'll go is to solve this
by oracle cause to the hole in her home
gasps and once we solve them and we can
plug in the CIJ of those zeros in this
sum to recover the original the value of
the original instance but somehow this
system this system is ranked efficient
like we can't solve it very simple
example here is just like if i have x +
y is equal 1 x plus 1 points to the
equals 3 we can't solve x and y windows
equals 1 but we only can say like x plus
1 equals 0 our system if we look at you
beastiality like one minute also we
realize that for this term as long as
the Cape a cell is some cell number and
m is another number the any of these
terms will have the same coefficient on
similar to this therefore we can not
solve them exactly but we can solve this
ahmad and that's good enough somehow
because x qm we can define is x qm which
is to let cape a cell to be killed and
Sam and I passage a will be in- them and
it's already in the whole of the value
is just some over this I plus J sin of
CI j 00 and such on this is exactly X 0
0 and see if we can solve this ax 0 0
then we can also recover the original
value that we can a new linear system
are looking like this whereas is index
and okay that's right this thing as they
are fed as a coefficient is this coming
solve this the answer is still no
unfortunately this is still angry fish
in the system because it's not hard work
though this eternity the things that
there are two there are like this the
column index by qm m can be written as
the sum of two other columns so we have
this equation like qm is a QP q minus 1
M plus Q as 2 n plus 1 so that means we
need to do more operations so what we do
we sort of a split xqm distributed into
the two variables humans why I'm and if
you want to impress one and so we will
define new variables recursively from Q
equals n 22 to do this thing so new
variable will be the plus so x cube
minus 1 m will be x qm + the old xq mens
1m and similarly for q minus 2n plus 1
so let's let's see what this operation
really does and we can write down these
variables in a triangular way and for
concreteness a link of six will start
from X 60 and we will rewrite 50 as the
old 50 plus X 60 and the 41 as for 1
plus 60 and recursively will do this for
50 and 51 and we do this for 40 41 42
and so on so forth then we do the only
after were doing all these things
we'll get another system and which
voyage the unknowns we don't really know
what these annals me because each of
this new variable will have contribution
from a pass to the to the vex 60 however
one thing to notice is that XD return in
sitting in his lonely corner it's
untouched so x0 the only value that we
care is not changed after all these
operations and indeed after doing all
these the book a show that the system is
is all wrapped and we can solve it then
the earnings we have saw access their
zero and means we can solve the value of
the original instance okay this is a
interpolation proof of one of the cases
in other cases this system we'd only do
all this stuff away is we just show this
Frank it takes some effort but it works
out ok so let's finish my talk with some
much so improving this this is a
technology theorems the first thing at
least what I do is to guess the
trackball cases and the next step is
just show anything else is hot ok
however each time I do these things
there are always some new types of cases
when we go from CSP Holland we discover
these vanishing things when we go from
Holland to planar hold and we discover
this is a orientation coffee orientation
stuff so the question is I could eat
them or like if we extend the further
our settings as iam some undiscovered
lurking tractable cases that's what I
six the most interesting question and to
consider some for the future directions
we kind of understand the planar graphs
very well no but what about the more
general hmn are three graphs I believe
we don't even have a good on studying
for accounting for the matching Zin hmm
three graphs I think that reduces talk
at this hour
we'll talk more about this dark and also
we can extend with a higher domains like
send to a symmetric functions and again
the question is is there more tractable
cases and can we fund them can we show
up and anything else it has okay
so do you have a explicit
projection for this closure of the
connection
yeah he's listen so far yes yeah I'm not
sure actually because let's say in
paragraphs we have this new orientation
problem I don't really know how to
explain that in this closure some penis
for the other cases rather for classes
we have understand it's like very well
and we can explain it we have a nice
explanation of this Universal approach
but for the new thing we don't really
know I think that tell means we haven't
understood everything yet for one thing
Jack as you say the first line is de
tractable no we don't have I don't have
expressive such a rational
interesting question
you